hello my name is Jorden santel from
Google daydream WebEx our team and I'm
excited to share with you our
explorations and augmented reality on
the web our team is very much like a R&D
type team and where we're exploring how
AR and VR will act on the web in the
future so what is augmented reality if
you've used Pokemon go snapchat filters
you already know what augmented reality
is but more formally AR is the
compositing of the digital world on top
of the real world
AR is very similar to VR in terms of
this immersive spectrum so if you take
AR and completely everything is in the
virtual world all opaque then that
becomes VR so immersive computing is
technology that operates on human
immersion when that's on the web we call
it the immersive web so we've been
dreaming a lot about the future of the
immersive web five to ten years from now
and I'm excited to share with you the
story of our foundational block of work
for this bringing augmented reality to
the web and also talked a little bit
about what's coming up next in the near
future what could be going on in ten
years from now as well as the challenges
it brings and why this is an exciting
time to be jumping on this new medium so
last summer Apple released a Ark it
Google relate released AR core and these
are augmented reality SDKs for iOS and
Android devices this enabled mobile
developers to easily create augmented
reality applications and provides
real-world understandings so developers
can create content in order to interact
with that real world so developers
having easy access is only one half of
the equation the other half is do users
actually have access to a are capable
devices previously this was limited to
dedicated headsets expensive dedicated
headsets
and less stable platforms but these new
SDKs air core and air kit only require
sensors like gyroscope
accelerometer RGB camera things that you
can find on most modern smartphones so
no specialized hardware is needed so
right now there's around 600 million a
our core and air kit devices so they're
out there users can use them so it's the
perfect time to start bringing augmented
reality to the web and there's like 200
megabytes of animated gifts here so
might be a little slow some of these so
we built some prototype browsers web AR
on AR kit and web a are on AR core great
names and these are hacky web views that
we use to expose features from a arkad
air core to web content so first we had
to identify requirements of which
features we need in order to expose to
create these experiences so we
identified three high level requirements
that we would need to bring to the web
so first off we need to know where the
device is in 3d space its position and
orientation in order to sync our virtual
world on top of the real world so VR has
similar needs we also also have to track
the pose there and so we were able to
leverage a lot of the web viewer API
here so sometimes this is referred to as
six stuff or six degrees of freedom and
that's referring to tracking three axes
of position and three axes of
orientation we also need to expose the
camera stream and intrinsics intrinsics
in this case are things like the field
of view and perspective of a camera
again in order to sync our virtual world
with the real world mobile platforms
only allow one process to access the
camera at a time so since our AR
platform is using the camera we can't
also use getusermedia for example so we
have to have a another way to expose
this information and finally we need to
able need to be able to understand the
world around us in order to interact
with the real world so scene
understanding is this broad description
the catch-all term for the ability to
interpret the real world so for example
finding surfaces
to place an object on it or estimating
light in an environment so you can see
the brave line up there get scared when
the lights go out so these three
components are MVP features said and we
also of course had some goals for this
experiment first off
general API exploration we wanted to
look into the the ergonomics or
feasibility of different features that
we do expose so for example earlier
prototypes used tango smartphones and
these were smart phones with infrared
depth cameras on them similar to
something like Kinect so this gave us
around 30,000 3d points per frame to
position in the real world and use that
in our experiments so needless to say
pushing 30,000 3d points from the
platform to web content and sometimes in
this case to the GPU was non-ideal so we
learned our initial api for point clouds
was difficult to use in a in a
performant way we also wanted to
discover what's possible what kind of
things we can make so with pose tracking
and the camera feed we can do things
like build portals and since this is the
web we are also able to use physics
libraries and surface detection to make
an AR mic drop and we've also had to
build tools as we're developing these
experiences to debug what we're doing it
was very difficult before we had these
tools to do things like visualize the
surfaces so we know if like are we
finding a plane or we are we missing
what's going on here did I break
something and we also want to get
developers excited about these features
we wanted to developers to bug browser
vendors say hey we want this please
implement this and to convince our
organizations to check it out maybe this
is something we can use and we also
wanted to see what cool ideas people
came up with so concurrently while
working on these prototypes folks from a
handful of browser vendors that you see
up there we're working on web via our
2.0 later this was renamed to WebEx are
in or
to support both augmented reality and
virtual reality experiences so after a
year so there's now an implementation of
WebEx are inside of Chrome Canary I
think the latest one behind a flag and
all vendors that currently support
webview are all these all these ones
have all pledged to support the WebEx
r-spec as well after about nine months
of prototyping and working on standards
we now have a working version in a real
browser so kind of asterisk so when I
wrote this proposal 4GS con few months
ago I was kind of I had no idea what
what state this would be in by now but I
got pretty close it's about like two
weeks away we're going through the
renewal process right now and who knew
that shipping code to like billion plus
users was difficult so it will be behind
multiple flags and the API will change
for sure between several versions it's
very in flux so now that we have these
features enabled in a real browser we
were able to show this off at Google i/o
a few weeks back and so we have this
educational site showcase in a statue
from Mexico though and it's kind of like
this
kinda like a Wikipedia type article with
a model on there and we wanted to show
off the progressive enhancement concept
you know something very webby so if you
if you're viewing this on a desktop or
mobile browser you can move the statue
around with mouse and keyboard similar
to other kind of 3d WebGL content model
viewers but when you're viewing this on
a browser that supports a are features
with WebEx are you can also place it in
the world around you I swear the
performance is better than this gift
looks so you were able to place this
life-size statue in the real world
around you and these annotations you can
interact with click on them and since
this is just the web you can render
these annotations with just HTML and CSS
all the same web tools you're used to so
when we were showing this
from the web booth I'm sorry there was a
web booth and an Android booth at Google
i/o and we were at the Android booth
where I was at the Android booth so we
had a lot of Android developers kind of
check it out and you know their reaction
was they didn't quite believe this was
the web so it was a lot of great
feedback and confirmation that yes the
web can perform utley run WebGL
experiences you with AR so I mentioned
earlier scene understanding so the
initial implementation of augmented
reality in chrome only implements one
form of scene understanding a hit test
so this allows you to cast array out
from your device and intersect with the
real world somewhere some surface some
collision and this returns a 3d point if
found so commonly in AR applications you
have some sort of reticle that traces
real-world surfaces and displays an
indicator to the user indicating there's
a there's a surface I found here or no
surface and where that collision
occurred so how we implement this
reticle behavior is on every frame we
cast that array from the device and see
if we get a hit and if it hits the
surface we changed the reticle to
provide some visual feedback in this use
case we say hey we found a surface tap
again to place a model so I'm going to
show off some example code of
implementing this reticle and I don't
want to get too deep into this at all
for several reasons one it's not in
Canary yet and so and there will be
better resources to come better than me
talking about it like a code lab and
other documentation so so most of this
code code is the same as if you're doing
a VR experience with WebEx are we can
request a device from navigator XR and
we also need to create an X our
presentation context from a canvas
element so this is very similar to
getting a WebGL context from canvas and
this is the canvas that is visible to
the user and inject it into the Dom as a
big caveat there's absolutely no error
handling here that
to be done so then we also request the
session on that XR device passing in our
X our presentation context so this
request session is the part that's not
fully SPECT out for augmented reality
yet ideally in the future this is where
you would request specific augmented
reality features so you can kind of
react to different environments
different platforms can support
different features and right now once
this lands if you enable the augmented
reality flag everything's always they
are the camera feet will always be
rendering and the underlying AR platform
will always be running so it has you
know battery implications and as well as
privacy implications for head and using
these features so that'll that'll change
very soon so this is a lot of code right
here I know so there's a lot of
boilerplate this will all be abstracted
away behind libraries but really quickly
we need to set up another canvas that we
write the WebGL commands to so this gets
mirrored over to the X our presentation
context that we just injected into the
Dom so this is probably the weirdest
part of web X are you actually have two
canvases one that you write to that
isn't not in the Dom and one that
displays that content that is in the Dom
so it's very different than other kind
of 3d stuff so things of note here is we
create a frame of reference and for our
session and then we start a
requestanimationframe loop using our
sessions requestanimationframe we have
to hook into the native device in order
to sync everything properly so similar
to this is again we're working with 3d
so this is similar to other kind of
WebGL 3ks development where we have a
render loop so in our render loop we get
our devices pose and that contains like
an matrix representing our devices
position and orientation and then we
render every frame our virtual content
that's matches perfectly with our real
world and then we call this reticle
update function so this reticle is a
custom 3gs class it represents like a
disk on the ground that can trace
surfaces so in every frame we're calling
this update function and again I'm
glossing over all the details right here
but ultimately we need an origin point
and a direction vector representing this
line coming out of our device and we
have we have a variable hits and that's
an array of all the hits that we found
and it's very easy to not find any hits
if we're in low lighting or there's no
kind of discernible features on the
surfaces we're looking at so if we found
a hit great it will contain a 3d
position and orientation and we'll use
that to position our reticle and if we
don't have a hit maybe we can fade out
our reticle or hide it completely so no
worries if that didn't completely make
sense the webex r-spec can be difficult
to use especially if you're unfamiliar
with 3d on the web and I mostly just
wanted to share that the high-level
concepts and just just to show what it
looks like and there were most
definitely will be libraries that will
abstract this away so what's next in the
near future so like I said sometimes in
the next few weeks
AR will land in Canary behind a flag and
with this flag like I said augmented
reality will always be on so and we want
this to be more fine-tuned so the
request session API will have to be
fleshed out and right now we only
support hit tests that abstraction over
the underlying surface or mesh data that
the AR platform provides but in the
future we would like to expose things
like point clouds surfaces mesh light
estimation as well as things like
anchors which are abstract 3d points
that you can place around the world that
over time as the system understands the
scene better that will update and become
more accurate and right now we're hand
coding all this XR stuff there's a lot
of rough edges the spec is still under
development and we're making tools
internally as needed so libraries like
3GS currently supports some XR use cases
and in the future we imagine this would
also support
and if you're familiar with Mozilla's
a-frame webview our library after we
made our prototype browsers I think
someone like a week later made a our
component that worked great so that that
community is very proactive so we
imagine like all these libraries will
support creating AR for a better
experience rather than writing using the
API directly so what I'm talking about
right now is mostly mobile AR and this
provides a lot of immediate solutions
for things like shopping education and
entertainment and this is the only only
the beginning as the future gets much
more interesting and weird so that's you
know the immediate future the next few
months or year what about the next five
years a little further out we can
imagine computer vision and machine
learning being used with augmented
reality Mozilla has been working on
their own prototype browsers using AR
and they've been doing some research
with computer vision within web XR and
something that's been talked about a lot
in the AR industry is this concept of
the AR cloud or cloud anchors which lets
multiple users share their virtual world
so this feature is currently an air
course and works for iOS and Android but
this will be critical to have also on
the web unclear if it'll be different
services or part of the native API no
idea but this is necessary and critical
for multi-user immersive content and
hardware is making a lot of progress so
with the latest generation of VR
headsets these all-in-one headsets sixth
off tracking for VR is much more
accessible now rather than needing a
whole room set up where you're
installing affair what they're called
like lasers to track your movement and
also like an expensive
gaming computer essentially so we're
getting closer to these like smaller
accessible rather affordable
comparatively headsets that people can
use
and currently there are a are headsets
like microsoft hololens meta to Google
glass for enterprise and soon the magic
leap so these air headsets are already
out they're all quite expensive and
they're specialized hardware and in
Indies in this head mounted display AR
world
like those will be supporting browsers
so this specification also has to work
for mobile but as well as these head
mounted displays and these head mounted
displays will have new input paradigms
we won't have physical screens to
interact with the hololens has like a
pretty good support for like hand
gestures to interact with content as
well as the voice commands so we seem to
be trending towards that like a limited
physical interface and using more
computer vision machine learning to
interact with this virtual environment
so further out in the future and this is
again this is looking at trends making
informed guesses but at the end of the
day they're still guesses you know we
have we have no idea so head mounted
displays will evolve into you know hip
glasses with you know these AR
capabilities you know years out and you
know once we have these socially
acceptable headsets and we can anchor
content in the real world we can reframe
what immersive computing will look like
in the future contextualized information
that is highly scaleable discovered
serendipitously instantly accessible
secure and interoperable across devices
and that sounds a lot like the web so
imagine walking down the street as
contextual irrelevant content is
appearing
we're securely executing arbitrary
content which you know that's that's
what the web is for and in this future
our immersive user agents have even more
responsibilities it's necessary for
users to be able to control and filter
that content especially since content
can be obstructing our vision more
crossing the street for example so you
know it's pretty important we need to
get that right so these are just some
trends based off of
technology but in the future society
will drive immersive computing more so
than technological possibilities
cultures will define their relationships
with immersive technology based off
their social intimacy and privacy values
usage will be influenced by States
legislation or indifference on data
ownership net neutral in corporate
regulations a society's economic
equality will determine access to these
immersive technologies and therefore its
creators directions and applications and
the outcome of each groups
socio-political decisions will define
their relationship with this technology
we can have some societies that are
comfortable with ubiquitous always on
always recording head mounted displays
in public spaces and others could just
use it in as needed basis like for
education or training so our culture
laws and technology are all intertwined
and it's important to consider all this
within the context of society so there
are a lot of unknowns some are exciting
some are terrifying and within these
unknowns that's where we must exert our
influence we must design a future that
puts human first not existing power
structures and it's important to listen
to tech critics sci-fi writers and
groups underrepresented in tech and ask
how can this be used for evil this
ubiquitous always-on technology has
massive privacy implications and this
trend of cloud computing can could
contribute to some surveillance state
and so maybe we can steer this more
towards on device computing the
combination of augmented reality
computer vision and machine learning is
already being shopped around to police
departments around the world for facial
recognition purposes this could threaten
civil liberties until hour until or
unless our laws catch up with technology
unchecked capitalism could result in
hyper consumerism unless we have the
ability to control this content and if
this technology isn't accessible to all
then we can further increase the digital
divide separating between those who have
have not so we must constantly be
vigilant as technologists and steer this
towards good Patricia had a great talk
yesterday on ethics that all that
applies here as well but enough about
the terrifying parts there's also a lot
to be excited about so we are in
uncharted lands we're learning about
this medium as it's being created and as
we go so Apple Microsoft Google have all
published these UX guidelines and
they're just scratching the surface of
what's possible now and in the future
you couldn't invent the next gesture
that is as ubiquitous as scrolling or
clicking and interacting with these
virtual objects and when when we're
talking about the web we have access to
hundreds of thousands of NPM packages
that we can use and mix and match in our
projects and there are no immersive
technology libraries currently so you
could invent the next jQuery or lodash
or react that is used in these
environments and I was originally going
to say there are no killer apps for VR
AR but I've played beat saver like
couple weeks ago and it's awesome
beat saver aside as an industry we're
still exploring what is the application
that gets people to jump into virtual
reality and augmented reality to get
over that initial friction so since
immersive computing is this
multidisciplinary field I think I think
we're gonna see a lot of new
collaborations coming out so like a
fashion designer and a historian or a
machine learning expert in a social
worker or in this case an audio engineer
and a Jedi so it's a super exciting time
to start these new collaborations as
engineers and designers Matt Meese Nicks
has a great article on a our first
applications and something that's stuck
with me here is with new mediums we
mostly just pour the previous or older
mediums into it so like when mobile was
a new thing we mostly just had tiny
websites on our phones it wasn't until
we started leveraging things like
location and
and access are always connected devices
that we truly leverage the platform with
things like Twitter and and lift and
same with augmented reality a lot of
augmented reality applications are kind
of just putting 2d content around the
world and you know a lot of it's like
well this could have just been a website
and this would have been easier so we're
still discovering what is what are the
applications that truly leverage the new
this new medium and that's it's still
important to play around and explore and
have fun with this medium so before I'm
done I'll leave you with a few links the
immersive web community group is on
github you can contribute and follow
along with the WebEx r-spec there and
Mozilla's a-frame is a great technology
that uses web components to create VR
and augmented reality seems you don't
have to be familiar with 3d or WebGL or
any of that stuff and the immersive web
weekly is a newsletter I started a few
weeks ago
that's summarizing all that's happening
in this like fast-moving space so be on
the lookout for a are landing in Chrome
Canary very soon and hope you all
explore the future Thanks